see how much we change women's lives we
get messages from women
i'm not bleeding i can be a mother again
i can be a wife i can work wow normally
and these things really you know give us
goosebumps and really push us forward
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of make-a-wish israel and tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret core adventures j ventures
riverside fm
fusion vc
birthright excel j impact leap google
for startups and hippo and in media
partnership with ctec
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
this episode is about entrepreneurship
in women's health career journeys
and really a both an informative and
inspiring episode and i hope you enjoy
meet keren leshem kieran is currently
the ceo and board director at ocon
healthcare a leading women's health
biotech company with a mission to
introduce innovative intrauterine drug
delivery technology for an array of
conditions and diseases to improve and
impact women's health and quality of
life
prior to ocon miss lesham headed the
corporate development team at the
european pharma company visa vistapharma
in addition she was a board member of a
bio light company vaisay which you
previously headed a ceo and an open
university lecturer in marketing and
business
as the founder and ceo of isai licensed
from nasdaq erie amongst other positions
in pharma and medtech miss slash
successfully led clinical r d and
business development activities to
achieve commercial status and mtas in
the united states european union and
china missed lesson was recently
featured in forbes magazine and sits on
the femtech labs admissions and advisory
board as well as lsx's advisory board
and is a mentor at the 8400 health
network
she makes sure to lead with passion
integrity and donate her time and her
earnings to and with women entrepreneurs
that are starting out their career path
and those whom have made choices that
require mentoring
[Music]
so excited to get inspired from you in
these next 20 minutes your work is
fascinating not just your work today as
ceo
of of ocon healthcare but you know
generally your whole career trajectory
in
in in the healthcare space i think it's
so cool all these different
organizations you've been a part of
today focusing on on women's healthcare
and i'm really excited to hear your
journey your perspective why you got
inspired and passionate to join this
company yourself and i think those
changes are always fundamentally so
inspiring for me as a young entrepreneur
and as a lifelong learner so karen thank
you so much for being here sure my
pleasure thanks michael for having me
of course well take me back a little bit
to sort of what excites you in this
world what what you know what are things
that are that you're curious about and
and then we'll transition to to
understanding a little bit better about
women's healthcare and how you got
introduced into this space
well i kind of stumbled across this
space i uh dealt in the field of
ophthalmology for about 15 years so that
was my whole world
um
you know which is important you know eye
disease is is crucial if we lose our
eyesight um you know it but it never
really uh
came home for me um i don't even need
reading glasses and i'm well well over
40. so um so yeah it was something i did
um i think my entire career brought me
to what i'm doing today uh really yeah
and so um i really thought about this
the other day looking at the questions
that you asked me i really think that
every step in my career brought me to do
the best i can be and do
for my team for the world for my boards
um wow okay so yeah i really believe
that okay so so okay so we have to just
jump right in there tell me a little bit
about what you're doing today but but i
wanna throughout these 20 minutes always
go back and figure out how did your
experiences sort of shape who you are to
allow you to be the best leader you can
be today in women's healthcare
so um i still don't want to know what i
want to do when i grow up
i kind of went from from a career to
career uh within the health space i knew
i wanted to be in healthcare but i just
didn't know exactly
and i studied business and so i kind of
stumbled across doing a lot of business
development but through my my career i
did a lot of work in managing projects
and doing business development mergers
and acquisitions and licensing and and i
really reached i think the top when i
worked for a pharmaceutical company in
europe and then i came back home
and i had options i had an option to
join ocon as vp sales and had another
option in a company in boston and i
thought boston would be awesome
uh but you know god in the world has a
way of of working uh in mysterious ways
and the boston
gig didn't come come through thankfully
because six months after that kovit hit
so i would definitely be uh looking for
a job uh and i joined yo khan and i
joined a company that was um in the
space of women's health i've never done
women's health i'm a woman you know i'm
worried about my health but you know we
don't know so much about our bodies and
about problems that we have and i was in
charge of one product um and to
understand why this product isn't
booming and i think very quickly the
boards um
approached me i knew them from from
earlier dealings and said you know this
company's not doing so well it's been
around for eight years we want to close
it what do you think
and i said you know i don't really know
and i looked at the patents and i
interviewed all kinds of key opinion
leaders and i said to myself we have to
bring these solutions to the market
women have to have access to better
therapeutics and better choices
um and so they uh made me ceo
and uh it's been an exciting hard
uh journey uh that we've that we've um
kind of embarked on uh to make sure this
platform that delivers drugs to the
uterus uh will be uh you know worldwide
available to women
so going back to that sort of a
consultation if you will internally from
whether whether you think there's
viability and continuing to fight for
this company or not you know but besides
the mission of you know of women's care
and and
better better drugs with for the uterus
and medicine for the uterus what what
was it about oak on healthcare that made
you understand that there is an
opportunity here that it sounds like you
were very convicted on sort of what that
this thing needs to be more accessible
to women worldwide is it because of the
technology of open healthcare or the
product itself what made you so so
convicted on this
so aid the technology it's super cool
it's super cool it's super safe i'm
using it myself i'm using one of our
products and i see i see the difference
i see how much i love it i see my
friends that are uh um eligible for it
using it and loving it um and i said to
myself you know this is not about one
product this is about a platform of
products that can help and i'll give you
an example we're working on a product
called seed and this product is an
intrauterine device but it's actually a
therapeutic it helps women
one in four that have abnormal or heavy
menstrual bleeding and in this arena
women have two choices either you're
pumped with hormones or uh you go to the
hospital to get you know your lining of
the uterus physically removed not to
mention the fact that doctors want to
take out our uterus when we don't need
it anymore after the age of 40. and this
is a simple product that goes in and out
and kind of does a chemical peel to the
endometrium um it's not supposed to be
painful it's done in the doctor's office
we don't need to have this insanely
invasive procedure and this is now in
clinical studies this has to come to
market one in four women suffer from it
and then we have an array of products
that continue on to women taking oral
formulations that don't really require
all of the systemic absorption so we can
you know target the tissue directly at
the uterus and so
the the technology the patents um the
idea behind it and i think that our
passion not only me together with my
team and my board brought the world
economic forum to put an eye on ocon and
we recently won
um a tech pioneer one in a hundred
companies globally creating impact so
it's not just what i think and what the
team thinks you important things yeah so
we really got uh recognition for it uh
very cool technology
incredible i love it so going back
obviously you know
women's health care is an exploding
field and so much innovation and
massive importance
you mentioned right before we started
that
you know the the sort of coming into the
realization of what is oakland
healthcare in this space it's something
that you became very passionate about
personally
what what is it you know sort of what is
it about the space the the the problem
space the the you know on a worldwide
scale that got you so so intrigued and
convicted
so just talking to women around the
world we just don't know our bodies we
don't know our options uh sometimes we
blindly go and listen to what the
doctors have to say they have an array
of priorities that that you know from
financial to just making sure that we're
kept quiet or just not complaining
um and so it really became apparent that
from not knowing our bodies and not
knowing our options companies need to
get out there and do a lot more work to
allow women to have these options and to
talk about some of their conditions that
today you know we just don't talk about
and ocon can be part of that of course
there's a huge uh ecosystem around it
and i also made sure that i'm gonna help
the ecosystem because the more companies
that come into the space and are
successful and
yeah will be uh important for the space
in general
so you still feel that today
it's a bit uh you know i have a daughter
i have a mother i have girlfriends uh
you know i have family we're all women
so um it's it's something personal as
well no but but it sounds like what
you're touching on besides the the
importance of it is is the fact that
there's market education that needs to
happen that there's not yet enough
attention being given to this given the
magnitude of the problem
i'd love to understand that a little bit
more
why you know it's 2022. you know why why
is it still the fact that you feel that
we don't give enough respect and
attention to
half of the world's
you know
health care issue i mean it's it's
pretty dramatic unfortunately it's not
only healthcare but it's also healthcare
um look at endometriosis for example
endometriosis is a condition where part
of the lining of the uterus is kind of
uh outside uh working as if it's in the
uterus but outside in other organs super
super painful and when women come to
doctors and complain about pain oh it
could be psychological
uh you're complaining but it must not be
that bad
and just now we're getting uh more and
more information on endometriosis they
say that one in ten women have it i'm
sure it's a lot more wow that's because
the
the fact that our diagnostics aren't you
know uh there and i think this continues
on and on in terms of what the doctors
are taught or not taught looking in the
in
the uk for example now all of the
doctors need to have a specific training
on women's health women have a different
really depression of diseases women have
different ways of expressing heart
attacks uh women have different ways and
different you know needs and so
i think that this is changing it's going
to be slow but at least the direction is
a good direction
and so what role does oak on healthcare
or do you personally as the ceo of
oakland healthcare play in sort of this
bigger
bigger you know
sort of push for women's health care
not just from a technology perspective
but from a
i guess market educational perspective
so first of all we are a therapeutics
platform i think one of the things that
are missing in women's health or more
therapies therapies are hard to come by
because most of the clinical studies are
not done in women only right these are
clinical studies that are done on the
population and most of them are are
white men just because you know you
don't want to have differences in in
your data because women have their
monthly hormonal changes for example so
a focusing on on women's health and in
clinical studies in women is super
important and i think ocon brings that
therapeutic edge a lot of assets in
women's health are digital
uh apps um other assets could be
diagnostics but not a whole lot of
therapeutics and so when you have such
an incredible platform that is safe and
can bring drugs to the uterus in a way
that's less painful
um and a little bit more targeted i
think that's super important worldwide
and also coming from israel i'm
zionistic and uh you know this is ours i
believe this is ours not not mine or oh
cons uh this is ours and we need to make
sure to to you know push and and be the
startup nation also in in women's health
i love it okay so so we have just a few
minutes left and i want to make sure
that you know i i learn a lot about this
space especially because it's a space
that unfortunately i don't know much
about and and honestly that's a problem
so so tell me a little bit about you
know oak on healthcare the different
products that you provide and and what
what health issues they help overcome
today
so we we built a platform um that's
shaped as a three-dimensional ball
uh that kind of rolls inside the uterus
it doesn't have any sharp edges it's not
made of plastic
to really bring
therapeutics to the target tissue so
women have an array of diseases and
conditions and indications in the uterus
from heavy menstrual bleeding to
contraception needs endometriosis
uterine fibroids um
endometriosis as i mentioned but also
menopause
so we we cater to that specific drug
delivery to the target tissue instead of
taking oral formulations that as i
mentioned go throughout our entire blood
system but you know these are expensive
hobbies but we still have a dream to
also put a little chip
on our balls to have kind of what we
call an internal wearable where we can
monitor um disease progression we can
monitor our vitamins and minerals
and and get a lot of information from
within our bodies and so we really want
to be a leader in the delivery of drugs
to the uterus to help with uterine based
conditions
how how big how important is this sort
of on the market education for for
doctors organic gynecologists versus
market educations for the end consumers
in other words is this something that
the average people need to understand or
is it just the doctors that need to get
educated about this yeah it's both
that's such a good question we really
need to work in both angles we need to
show the doctors that innovation is
coming and they're able to use the same
platform for the treatment of different
diseases and indications but also women
women need to be a lot more educated
about their options and to ask you know
we we live in israel where women are a
lot more
progressive and they ask questions and
they talk to their doctors and really
push uh in other markets it's less uh uh
prevalent
but um but yeah we need to make sure to
to give both the uh women
the men also but also the the healthcare
professionals uh and these are two very
different um educational kind of
pathways that we need to create
absolutely and so how do you how how do
you think strategically around getting
this out to women worldwide sort of
market education 101
how does how how do you even take a
product like this and
educate a large population about what it
does and what problems it may solve yeah
well i think that that today um digital
channels are fantastic they can do much
harm
because the loudest you know voices are
the ones that complain but they can also
do a lot of good and women today when
they take a moment and they look online
on what's available they may come across
different
applications different uh products and
this is something we will continue to
invest in as as we move forward ocon is
a um is an r d house and also a
manufacturer of this platform technology
we want to be able to to give
distributors or partners uh these
products because they know what they're
doing in the market in terms of
commercializing these uh these assets
and so you know we want to help with
databases and we want to help this reach
but i think digital platforms are going
to be extremely useful uh for continued
education uh for women and definitely
through the world economic forum let's
see how much we can help with change
policy through normal organizations yeah
so so looping back to sort of your own
story here
you know how is this journey different
from previous journeys that you've had
you mentioned that you know one of the
things that were really cool you
mentioned that
you know it almost seems like a lot of
the things you've done sort of have
brought you to this point how how is
that so how do you why why do you think
that
so in my journey up till this point i've
done a lot in different areas of a of a
startup right so i've done uh clinical
and regulatory and project management
and and funding and but every time i did
a part of it
here at ocon and i always say there's no
company like okan in israel especially
not in women's health because here we
have it all we do manufacturing we have
labs for our um research and development
we do commercialize um we need to get
money in order to fund these uh these
hobbies um and the whole management of
it managing the board managing the staff
uh working together with a team of of
brilliant people so this all comes
together uh at ocon there's not one
portion right this is a whole ecosystem
um that i've been very privileged to be
able to to manage and be part of so um
so i really think that all the little
things that i've done all over the years
uh or throughout the years brought me uh
here
love it
so you see you see you seem very
inspired by what you do where do you get
that inspiration from i guess sort of on
on a regular basis so is it is it more
so from the
from the you know high you know the the
goal you're trying to achieve the
problem that you're solving or is it
more on a day-to-day basis that some
things are making just inspired by what
you do um it's both i think that the
prospect of where we're going to be and
how much work we've done in the last
couple years when we we've restarted the
company to see this huge change that
we've made already and what the future
holds is super inspiring but i think the
day to day is even more um meaning the
team here we're mostly women um we all
have issues it's not us it's our
daughters it's our sisters it's our
family and so the day-to-day working
with an incredible team is really
something that gives me a lot of uh you
know motivation to get up in the morning
and and to be here and and to do this
work and to really progress it and now
and we see we have clinical studies now
we see how much we change women's lives
we get messages from women
i'm not bleeding i can be a mother again
i can be a wife i can work wow normally
and these things really you know give us
goosebumps and really push us forward
so uh it's incredible
i love it karen i really want to thank
you for taking the time and sharing with
me i think that beyond beyond the
awesome work that it sounds like you're
doing at oakland healthcare and in your
own journey just sounds like
there's this whole shift now in the
market of of of better education for
understanding
different health care needs and it still
astonishes me how little we know
not just about women's healthcare but
about also companies that are dealing
with it and we've had quite a few on the
on this show including oak on healthcare
and to me it's oh it's constantly you
know it's amazing to me how how much we
talk about tech and biotech and medicine
and you know the day-to-day but but very
rarely we get to to these topics still
and so thank you for pushing the
envelope here and for making it more
accessible well thank you michael for
giving a stage
uh for us to be here and to listen to
what we're doing this was wonderful it
was awesome
thank you thank you for the work good
luck karen
[Music]